[Musique]
l'école de 1600 est une école en
alternance qui vise à former des cyber
défenseur en l'école ouvrira normalement
le 13 octobre dans l'ancien musée la
ville de saint quentin en yvelines dans
le 78 nous visons une centaine
d'étudiants pour la première promotion
qui aura lieu en septembre 2021 la
première partie enseignement en présence
à l'école deuxième partie enseignement à
distance
troisième partie présence en entreprise
l'intérêt pour nous était de répondre à
un besoin d'ancrer habilité sûr que les
entreprises aujourd'hui sont parties
prenantes sur la conception des
programmes de courses que des poteaux
essentiel et plutôt que d'attendre trois
ans pour que la première promo soient
disponibles sur le marché
ça nous permet aujourd'hui d'avoir
aujourd'hui des étudiants qui soit
directement opérables et qui répondent
aux besoins des entreprises
ça sera à titre de niveau 7 qui équivaut
à bac +5 avec un titre d'experts en
gestion des systèmes sécurité
informatique
l'inscription se fait sur le site école
2600 points comme le processus de
sélection est assez strict on va
sélectionner étudiants sur dossier puis
par entretien de motivation puis
entretien technique pour être en
capacité d'offrir aux entreprises le
plateau de paris saclay les meilleurs
candidats dans domaine de la
cybersécurité
[Musique]
l'industrie est en tension on a un
manque de 10000 emplois dans le domaine
de la cyber et suite à l'annoncé du
président de la république sur le plan
d'un milliard pour pouvoir relancer la
filière
on estime qu'il faudra horizon 2025
avoir 45 mille postes dont trente mille
sont vacants